Sabe aquela história do ômega3 faz bem
pro coração? Pois é, tem muita gente
questionando isso, vários estudos aí
sendo talvez mal interpretados. Tem um
pega ali que eu preciso explicar
direitinho para vocês. E olha, esse
assunto é mais interessante do que você
imagina, porque envolve um conceito de
estatística que eu mesmo não conhecia
bem e que mudou completamente a maneira
como a gente entende essa suplementação.
Então, antes de começar, eu quero que
vocês saibam que essa live surgiu de uma
pergunta que eu recebi várias vezes ao
longo das últimas semanas. Pacientes
chegando aqui no consultório confusos.
Doutor, eu vi na internet que ômega-3
causa arretmia. Será que faz mal? E
agora eu faço o quê? Então essa confusão
tem fundamento, pessoal, porque
realmente existem estudos mostrando que
ômega-3 pode causar arritmia, mas também
existe estudos mostrando que ele salva
vidas. Então como é que a gente concilia
isso, né? Como é que pode isso? Então,
né? Parece confuso. Então, pega uma
água, pega um cafezinho, senta aí
confortavelmente
no seu sofá, na sua poltrona, vamos
conversar como se você estivesse aqui na
minha sala. Eu vou explicar tudo
mastigadinho e no final vocês vão
entender porque que essa aparente
contradição, na verdade, faz todo
sentido, OK?
Então, primeiro vamos deixar claro, o
ômega-3 realmente funciona, pessoal. Não
é papo furado. Tem uma pancada de estudo
mostrando isso. Olha só, tem uma
metaanálise gigantesca. Eu estou falando
de mais de 120.000 pessoas acompanhadas
por anos e que mostrou uns resultados
bem impressionantes. O ômee 3 ele
reduziu em 28% o risco de infarto.
Pessoal, isso não é brincadeira. quase
1/3 a menos de chance de ter um evento
cardiovascular. Para vocês terem uma
ideia do que isso significa, se numa
população de 1000 pessoas 100 teriam
infarto, com ômega-3 apenas 72 teriam.
Então são 28 vidas salvas a cada 1000
pessoas. Diminui também em 19% os
eventos coronarianos maiores. É coisa
séria mesmo. E não para por aí. Esse
danado baixa triglicides, que é uma
beleza. Então, estamos falando aí de 25
a 30% de redução. Para quem tem
triglicerides ou trigliceridos nas
alturas, então trata-se de um santo
remédio. Então, eu lembro de um paciente
meu que chegou aqui no consultório com
triglice de 800 ng por ml. 800.
O sujeito praticamente tinha mel
ocorrendo nas veas. Então, depois de 3
meses ômega-3 bem dosado, baixou para
280. Ainda não era o ideal, mas que
diferença, não foi? Então, mecanismo de
ação do ômega-3 é fascinante. Ele tem
dois principais componentes, como muitos
de vocês já sabem, é o EPA e o DHA. são
siglas, significa
e cosa penteno e docosa exenoico. O EPA
ele funciona como guardião das células
do coração. Ele mantém aquela pelizinha,
aquela camadinha interna do endotélio
que reverte, reveste as artérias por
dentro, funcionando de maneira redonda.
É tipo deixar o encanamento da casa bem
olleado, OK? Então, sem ferrugem e sem
entupimento. Então, o EPA é bom paraa
artéria de modo geral e o DHA mais para
sistema nervoso de modo geral. Então,
DHA tem esse papel aí de ajudar os
neurônios. Esse componente faz uma
faxina neurológica que vocês não têm
ideia. Estudos mostram que pode ajudar a
prevenir várias doenças degenerativas,
como Alzheimer, melhorar a memória, a
concentração, é alimento pros neurônios.
E tem mais, ômega-3, ele é um
anti-inflamatório e não é um
aninflamatório fraco. Ele compete com
omega 6, que a gente em geral consome em
excesso.
E essa competição comega 6 vai causar
uma redução de produção de substâncias
inflamatórias, tá? Então, a gangue do
bem, né? Os ômega-3 brigando com a
gangue do mal dentro das nossas células.
Mas vamos ao plot switch dessa história,
o lado sombrio do ômega-3. Aí, pelo
menos nesses estudos que surgiram nos
últimos meses. Agora chegou a parte que
deixa todo mundo de cabelo em pé. Então,
estudos recentes, e quando eu digo
recente, é coisa de 2024, mostraram que
ômega-3 pode aumentar o risco de
fibrilação atrial. E não é pouquinho,
né? Estamos falando aí em torno de 25 a
49%. Doses altas acima de 4 g por dia,
praticamente dobraram o risco de
arritmia. Então, pacientes que tomaram
mais de 1 g por dia apresentaram risco,
segundo esses estudos, 49% maior
desenvolver fibrilação atrial. Doses
intermediárias, tipo 1,8 g, já
aumentaram em 84%. Eu sei que os números
assustam, mas eu vou explicar essa
contradição, vocês vão entender.
As doses padrão, que seria 840 mg por
dia, não dariam problema aparente. Então
vocês já viram aqueles remédios que em
dose baixa curam, em dose alta poderiam
causar problema? Então ômega-3 seria
meio assim. Eu não concordo com isso. Já
vou explicar porque que deu esses
resultados, tá? O mecanismo é meio
contraditório, né? Então ele
estabilizaria as membranas do coração,
né, o ômega-3, mas ao mesmo tempo ele
mexeria com os canais de cálcio, só de
potássio. Isso poderia dar problema.
Então, mas eu quero deixar claro, eu não
concordo com muitas das conclusões
desses estudos. Eu vou apresentar para
vocês aqui uma explicação clara do
porquê desses achados contraditórios,
porque que eles acontecem. Então, segura
um pouco a ponta aí que eu já falo desse
assunto, OK?
Então existiria também uma possível
associação entre altos níveis de ômega-3
e aumento do risco de câncer e próstata.
Per, não é para entrar em pânico, tá? É
bom saber que existe esses estudos
também, eu acho que estudos que tiveram
problemas estatísticos, doses muito
altas por muito tempo poderiam também
reduzir a função do sistema imune. O
corpo ficaria meio preguiçoso para
reagir às infecções. De novo, eu não
concordo com isso. Eu acho que isso não
são problemas estatísticos, mas vamos
falar dos problemas um pouco mais
adiante.
Outro ponto importante, risco de
sangramento. Mas esse risco só vale para
doses muito altas mesmo de ômega-3, tipo
seis ou mais cápsulas por dia. O EPA em
altas doses aumentaria em 50% o risco
relativo de sangramento. É um aumento
modesto, cerca de 0,6 se a gente for
falar de risco absoluto, mas quem toma
anticoagulante precisa ficar muito
atento quanto a isso. E tem mais, tem um
estudo chinês gigante que foi publicado
no British Medical Journal e acompanhou
mais de 415.000 pessoas por 12 anos. E o
resultado para quem é saudável, o
ômega-3 poderia aumentar em 13% risco de
fibrilação atrial e 5% de AVC. Mas esa
aí, presta atenção nos detalhes. Isso
valeria para pessoas saudáveis. Para
quem já tem problema cardíaco, a
história muda completamente. Então,
nesse mesmo estudo gigante, pessoas que
já tinham doença cardiovascular tiveram
15% menos progressão da fibrilação trial
para imparato e 9% menos morte por
problemas cardíacos. Tá ficando confuso?
Eu peço desculpas por isso, eu entendo,
mas tem uma explicação muito elegante
para isso. Então, acompanha até o final
para você entender o que eu tô falando.
E aqui entra uma das maiores descobertas
da medicina moderna sobre como
interpretar dados científicos.
Antes de falar dos riscos competitivos,
eu preciso contar para vocês uma
história que vai explicar porque que os
estudos sobre ômega-3 são tão
contraditórios. É tipo um episódio do
CSI Médico, não sei se vocês conhecem
esse seriado americano aí de
investigação científica, né? Então vou
contar a história de dois estudos
gigantes que chegaram a conclusões
opostas. O primeiro chama-se reduce it e
o outro é o strength. Os dois tentaram,
desculpa, os dois testaram o ômega-3 em
milhares de pessoas, mais um deu
positivo e o outro deu negativo. E como
é que pode isso? Vou explicar.
O reduce, ele testou o EPA puro, né, o
Ecosa pentenico, que é aquele do
coração, contra um placebo de óleo
mineral. OK? Então, de um lado placebo,
que seria entre aspas pílula de farinha,
mas nesse caso é óleo mineral, e de
outro lado EPA. Qual foi o resultado?
Seria fantástico, né? Esse estudo houve
redução de infarto de derrame no grupo
de ômega-3 em relação ao placebo com
óleo mineral. Funcionou que é uma
beleza. Aí a galera comemorou Eureca
ômega-3 funciona. Mas aí veio o outro
estudo strength que testou o EPA mais
DHA contra o placebo. Só que agora não é
mais óleo mineral, óleo de milho. E o
resultado? Nada, zero benefício. O
estudo foi até interrompido antes do
tempo porque não estava dando em nada.
Mas pô, como assim pensaram os
pesquisadores aí que descobriram o
problema. O placebo não era placebo.
Isso acontece muito. Estudo mais do que
você imagina. Então, no reducit, o
placebo de óleo mineral, ele causou um
estrago nos pacientes. Ele aumentou o
LDL colesterol em 10%,
a proteína Creativa em 32%, a
polipoproteína B em quase 8%. Ou seja, o
placebo estava fazendo mal. Então não
era só o ômega-3 fazendo bem, era o
placebo fazendo mal também.
É como se você testasse um remédio
contra veneno. Claro que o remédio vai
parecer fantástico comparado ao veneno,
entendeu? Mas se você testar o mesmo
remédio contra água, aí a história muda.
Não sei se vocês captaram, mas tentei
simplificar o máximo possível. Então, no
estudo strength o placebo de óleo de
milho não fez mal nenhum. Aí o ômega-3
teve que mostrar o seu valor real sem
nenhum tipo de truque e nesse estudo não
teve benefício significativo.
Isso é só a ponta do iceberg dos
problemas metodológicos. Tem mais coisa
ainda. Muitos estudos usam ômega-3 velho
oxidado, que é tipo óleo de cozinha
velho. Ele não funciona direito. Então,
outros usam doses baixíssimas que nem
chegam a alterar os níveis de sangue. E
tem o viés, né, de publicação também.
Tem estudos que mostram malefício.
Esses estudos que são mais focados em
malefício, eles são publicados mais
facilmente que estudos positivos. Vocês
já ouviram falar daquela história que
notícia ruim vende muito mais? Então
vale nesse caso aqui outro problema,
qualidade de suplementos.
Diferente de remédio, os suplementos não
passam por controle tão rigoroso, né?
Então tem estudo mostrando que muitos
produtos de ômega-3 no mercado estão
oxidados, como já comentei, contaminados
ou com doses diferentes do que está no
rótulo. Aqui vem uma informação que pode
mudar tudo. O EPA isolado, ele pode
funcionar melhor que a combinação EPA e
DHA para questões cardíacas. Tem alguns
estudos mostrando isso. É como se fosse
dois remédios diferentes, né? O EPA
separado DHA e o EPA mais o DHA. OK?
Isso tem que ser confirmado por mais
estudos, mas alguns desses sugerem essa
questão. Agora que vocês entenderam
porque que os estudos são tão confusos,
eu vou explicar o conceito que realmente
mudou, como a gente interpreta tudo
isso, tá? aqui que a coisa fica
interessante de verdade. Tem um conceito
na estatística chamado riscos
competitivos
que explica essa aparente contradição do
ômega-3. Esse conceito ele é
revolucionário porque ele muda como é
que a gente interpreta os dados médicos.
Eu vou dar um exemplo bem prático para
vocês entenderem. Imaginem essa cena que
vocês têm duas formas de sair de cena,
ou seja, de vocês irem pro céu, OK? Ou
por infarto ou por arritmia. Então o
ômega-3 ele previne tanto o infarto que
as pessoas vivem tempo suficiente para
desenvolver arritmia. É tipo aquela
história, não morreu afogado, mas morreu
na praia. Então deixa eu contar uma
história real para ilustrar mais ainda
isso. Imagine dois grupos de 1000
pessoas cada um. No primeiro grupo, sem
ômega-3,
300 pessoas morrem de infarto aos 60
anos. No segundo grupo, ômega-3, apenas
200 pessoas morrem de infarto aos 60
anos. OK?
Maravilha? Então, salvamos 100 vidas,
OK? Mas aquelas 100 pessoas que não
morreram aos 60 anos continuam vivendo,
OK? Óbvio, né? Não morreram, continuam
vivendo. Então, aos 75 anos, algumas
delas desenvolvem fibrilação atrial,
coisa que jamais teria acontecido se
elas tivessem morrido de infarto aos 60.
Então, quando você analisa só fibrilação
arterial, parece que o ômega-3 fez mal,
mas na verdade ele fez tão bem que
permitiu que essas pessoas vivessem
tempo suficiente para poder ter um
problema mais na frente, menos grave.
Deu para entender? É como comparar duas
cidades. Em uma delas, as pessoas morrem
de acidente de trânsito aos 20 anos. Na
outra, elas vivem até os 80 e morrem de
câncer. Se você só olhar as estatísticas
de câncer, vai achar que a segunda
cidade é mais perigosa,
mas é óbvio que a segunda cidade é mais
saudável, né? Porque as pessoas
conseguiram viver até um ponto que elas
poderiam correr o risco de ter câncer.
Então os estudos tradicionais usam uma
metodologia chamada capl que não
considera isso direito. Então é como se
eles fossem contadores que só sabem
somar, mas não sabem interpretar o que
que os números significam. Então, quando
você usa a função de incidência
cumulativa, que é uma ferramenta
estatística mais sofisticada, que leva
em conta os riscos competitivos que eu
tô falando aqui, o cenário muda de
figura. Então, essa análise considera
que se você morreu de infarto, não pode
mais ter fibrilação atrial. Parece
óbvio, né? Mas muitos estudos acabam
ignorando isso na análise estatística.
Então, um dado interessante, a
fibrelação atrial, ela aumenta
exponencialmente com a idade. Então, a
cada década após 50 anos, o risco
praticamente dobra. Então, quando o
ômega-3 salva alguém de morrer de
infarto aos 60, essa pessoa vai
envelhecer e naturalmente vai ter o
maior risco de arritmia aos 70, 80, 90
anos.
A medicina moderna tem vários exemplos
disso. Por exemplo, nós conseguimos hoje
curar infecções que há mais de 100 anos
atrás matavam crianças, né? E o
resultado, essas crianças vão virar
adultas, crescem e hoje elas morrem de
câncer ou de outros problemas cardíacos
na velice. Então isso não significa que
os antibióticos são necessariamente
ruins, significa que eles funcionam tão
bem que permitiram que várias crianças
que não sobreviveriam chegassem à idade
adulta, a idade também idosa e vivessem
o suficiente para ter outros problemas.
Então acho que ficou claro esse
conceito, certo? Então, qual que é a
pegada na prática? Agora que vocês
entenderam toda a complexidade, vou dar
as dicas reais de como usar o ômega-3 de
forma inteligente. Primeiro cenário,
pessoa saudável, querendo prevenir
problemas cardíacos, que é o caso da
maioria das pessoas que estão assistindo
esta live.
Aqui a estratégia é doses baixas, 250 a
500 mg de EPA mais DH combinados por
dia. Então a autoridade europeia de
segurança alimentar considera doses de
até 5 g seguras, mas para prevenção
muitas vezes menos é mais. Então
preferencialmente
dividido em duas tomadas. Então assim,
você pega os benefícios
anti-inflamatórios e de proteção
cardiovascular sem esse risco. E aíbia,
como eu tô dizendo, esse risco não é
real, ele é um risco fabricado porque a
pessoa viveu tempo suficiente para
desenvolver a arretmia. Então vamos ao
segundo cenário. Pessoas com
triglicerides altos. Aí você pode usar
doses maiores, tipo 1 a 4 g por dia, mas
sempre com monitoramento cardíaco. Então
para triglicérides, o ômeega-3 é eficaz,
ele ajuda a baixar. reduz de 25 a 30% e
é um dos poucos suplementos que
realmente funciona para isso. Tem outros
aí que tipo berberina, tipo
exancotinato inosital, mas o ômeega-3 é
um dos tops. Terceiro cenário, a pessoa
que já teve infarto ou tem doença
coronariana já documentada,
estabelecida, aqui o benefício é muito
maior que o risco de suposta arritmia.
Então, mesmo que apareça essa arritmia,
a redução de morte pro problema
coronário compensa muito. Então, doses
de 2 a 4 g adequadas.
Em relação à qualidade, isso é crucial.
É a primeira regra, nem todo ômega-3 é
igual. A primeira regra, verifiquem se o
produto foi testado para contaminantes
como mercúrio, chumbo e dexinas. Então,
peixes grandes, tipo,
eh, atum, né, acumulam essas porcarias
aí. Então, tem várias marcas muito boas.
Eu vou comentar sobre algumas aqui. Eu
vou colocar na tela para vocês verem.
Eu particularmente sugiro o Omegaaper,
né? Omega é uma das melhores marcas que
nós temos disponíveis, mas temos também
outras boas marcas. Nós temos a Nutri
Blue Omegatec, óleo de crida pura vida,
tem o triple strength ômega da GNC,
ômega-3 triglicerides da Essênia, ultra
ômega-3 Anals,
ômega da Supranayak, ômega for plus
Vitafor. E se você quiser uma fonte
confiável paraa compra do Omegaapure, eu
vou deixar aqui o contato, tá aí na
tela, um telefone de WhatsApp para vocês
adquirirem. E lembrando que é só uma
sugestão, tem todas as outras marcas que
eu comentei que também são top, tão
estão aí na sua tela e vocês sempre
podem procurar suas próprias fontes para
compra online, tá? Ou compra direta na
loja. Então, falamos já da primeira
regra que é a qualidade.
Vamos falar agora da segunda regra.
Epa isolado parece ser mais eficaz que
combinações de EPA e DH para benefícios
do coração, tá? tem o seu objetivo foi
coração. É interessante buscar produtos
com mais EPA, tá? Agora, se o objetivo
for melhorar a cognição cérebro, aí o
pensamento, o raciocínio, aí eu sugiro
produtos com concentração maior de DHA.
Terceira regra, a forma molecular
importa. O ômega-3 na forma de
fosfolipídios, como no caso do óleo de
cri, tem absorção melhor que na forma de
triglicerídeos. Então, busque na forma
de trigliceridos e não decios grassos
livres. Então esse ômega-3 francamente é
melhor. É como comparar um remédio comum
como um remédio de liberação controlada.
Quarta regra, cuidado com a oxidação.
Ômega-3 oxida fácil, especialmente se
exposto à luz, calor ou oxigênio. Se o
produto tem cheiro forte de peixe ou
gosto ruim, tá oxidado. Então, nesse
caso, precisa jogar fora. Até aquele
teste você pode fazer de colocar o
ômega-3 no freezer ou no congelador. Se
ele formar cristais de gelo, se ele
congelar, é sinal de que é um produto de
má qualidade.
E uma dica interessante, sempre tome
ômega-3 com outras gorduras, né? Ômega-3
é uma gordura, lipossolúvel, então se
você ingerir mais gordura, vai ajudar na
absorção, vai ficar mais fácil de
absorver. Então eu recomendo tomar
sempre junto com uma refeição, nunca te
tomo o vazio. Pode ser com um pedaço de
abacate, com castanho, até mesmo junto
com outras gorduras.
Sobre o tempo, time, não existe um
horário mágico, mas consistência é muito
importante. Então, se você escolher um
horário, mantém aquele horário. E é
melhor tomar todo dia no mesmo horário
para não esquecer, tá? E seu corpo
precisa manter níveis estáveis desses
gráos aí do ômega-3. E uma informação
que pouca gente sabe, a proporção
ômega-3 para ômega6 é mais importante
que a quantidade absoluta de ômega-3. As
nossas dietas geralmente têm uma
proporção de 20 para um de ômega6 para
ômega-3. Então o ideal seria 4 para um,
né? Então isso tá bem longe da realidade
hoje das dietas. Então além de aumentar
ômega-3, é bom você diminuir os óleos de
sementes comuns ou até cortar. Só
utilizar esse tipo de óleo de maneira
indireta. Quando você não tiver escolha,
vai comer fora de casa. no restaurante,
você não vai escolher o óleo que foi
utilizado. Então, mas em casa use óleo
de coco, azeite de oliva para fazer uma
fritura rápida. Use até óleo de abacate
também
e corte o óleo de soja, o óleo de milho,
o óleo de girassol e o canola. E para e
para finalizar essa parte prática,
sempre façam exames regulares, façam
acompanhamento médico, especialmente se
tiverem tomando doses mais altas, né?
minimamente um hemograma, um
coagulograma e um eletrocardiograma. E
isso não é paranoia, é prudência, tá? E
fontes alimentares continuam sendo
ideais, né? Sardinha, cavalinha, né?
Peixe cavalo ou cavalinha, salmão
selvagem, chuva, peixes pequenos do mar
ou peixes de criação que não tem um
problema de comer ração.
Uma porção de 100 g de cavalo ou
cavalinha tem 4580 mg de com DHA. É
bastante coisas, né? Então, duas porções
de peixe gordo por semana e vocês estão
bem servidos também, tá?
Então, antes da gente responder as
perguntas, o que que nós aprendemos?
Então vamos fazer aqui uma recapitulação
do que nós aprendemos. Primeiro, a
ciência é complexa, cheia de nuances. Eu
sei que isso é difícil para muitas
pessoas entenderem e confuso. Não
existem respostas simples para questões
complexas. O ômega-3 não é nem santo nem
demônio. Ele é uma ferramenta poderosa
que tem que ser analisada com calma,
precisa ser usada com sabedoria e
conhecimento. Os estudos científicos
podem ser enganos se não entendermos a
metodologia. O caso, né, dos dois
estudos grandes que eu falei do reduc e
o strength nos ensinou que até o placebo
pode influenciar resultados. Isso nos
lembra de sempre questionar como é que
esse estudo foi feito. Terceiro, o
conceito de risco competitivo nos ensina
que às vezes um aparente problema pode
ser, na verdade, um sinal de sucesso
terapêutico. Então você viver mais, você
tá sujeito a mais risco, né? Isso que eu
falei durante a live.
Então, nós conseguimos evitar que as
pessoas morram de algum problema e agora
elas viveram tempo suficiente para ter
outros problemas. Isso não é falha, é
sucesso. Só que a estatística às vezes
não pega isso. O quarto ponto, a
qualidade importa mais do que
quantidade. Um ômega3 bem dosado, não
oxidado, na forma correta, vale mais que
doses cavalares de produto ruim. E
quinto, individualização é a chave. Não
existe dose única que serve para todo
mundo. Seu contexto de saúde, seus
exames, seus fatores de risco, tudo
importa na decisão. Então a mensagem que
quero deixar é: não saiam tomando
ômega-3 de maneira desordenada,
mas também não ten medo dele baseado em
alguma manchete sensacionalista.
A verdade está no meio como sempre e
precisa ser construída com conhecimento,
exames e acompanhamento adequado. E por
favor, pessoal, eu quero aquela
conversa, cada um fala uma coisa, cada
um fala uma coisa. Medicina não é
matemática exata e nunca vai ser. É arte
e ciência juntas. Compartilhe os vídeos,
faça bem.
A vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do Tolém
se volva.